[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
Joep, can you start
by clarifying what
exactly Google Cloud--
I'm sorry, what exactly Twitter
is moving to Google Cloud?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Thanks
for hosting us today.
We are migrating our ad
hoc and our cold storage
use cases to cloud.
That takes about a third of
our Hadoop infrastructure,
hence our project
name, Partly Cloudy.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: You
said ad hoc and cold.
What does that mean?
Ad hoc is exploratory
data analysis.
What's cold?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yeah, we
have different use cases
for different-- different
clusters for different use
cases.
Original data lands
on RT clusters.
That's where the
original data comes in.
Then ad hoc and exploratory use
cases run on ad hoc clusters.
Production clusters
run the repeat jobs
that run over, and
over, and over again.
Those sit on
production clusters.
And our cold storage
is more for data
that is less accessed
and less frequently used.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Is it fair
to say that the production
clusters are batch jobs
versus the ad hoc clusters are
kind of like off the cuff jobs?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yeah, most of
the jobs on the Hadoop clusters
are batch.
The difference between
production and ad hoc
is more that the
ad hoc interactive
and less predictable.
Whereas production jobs
are the repeat jobs
that run over, and
over, and over again
that are more predictable.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
Great, and I believe
you blogged about this
yesterday as well, right?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yes,
we have a blog post out.
And most of those
links will end up being
on cloud.google.com/twitter.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: So
why Google Cloud?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS:
A couple of years
ago, we ended up doing a large
evaluation of multiple vendors.
And we measured many
different things,
did a lot of benchmarking.
And particularly the
network capability,
the ability to be able to
separate storage from compute,
and to be able to scale
the compute independently
from the storage, those
were all deciding factors.
And then one of the other
very large deciding factors
was the technical capabilities
and the interaction
with all of the engineers
on the Google side
that has shown a great
partnership so far.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Cool--
so before getting
into the details of your
Hadoop infrastructure,
I'd like to get the audience
involved in our discussion.
Tweet your question
with this hashtag.
The hashtag will be repeated
throughout the future slides
on the bottom left.
Asheem, who's raising
his hand in the front,
will be sharing your questions
live from Twitter with us
throughout the panel, but also
at the end of the panel where
we'll do a dedicated
10 or 15 minutes Q&A.
So we won't be using
Dory for this session.
We'll take the questions live
from Twitter with the hashtag.
So let's talk about Hadoop
as it runs at Twitter
on prem at scale right now.
So these are pretty
massive numbers--
500,000 cores, more than
10,000 node clusters.
Lohit, can you talk a
bit about the challenges
involved with running
Hadoop at this scale?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Sure.
So there are several challenges.
But I would like to point out
that scalability is probably
the very top.
Whatever features we implement
or any new infrastructure
we plan to build, from
the very beginning we
consider scalability.
A couple of years back,
when we started off
with our Hadoop clusters,
we had about 2,000
node Hadoop clusters.
And that, at that time
the largest publicly known
Hadoop cluster was
about 4,000 nodes.
And our challenge,
our target, was
to build a 6,000 node cluster.
So right from HDFS, to YAM, be
it the applications, libraries,
for example, shared cache--
whatever features
we had to build,
we had to think
about scalability.
And today we have our
single largest clusters
are more than 12,500 nodes.
And we have multiple of them.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Yeah, I
mean, that's pretty amazing.
Is that one single
Hadoop cluster, one name
node that's serving
out 12,500 nodes?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: So that's
a very good question.
It's actually
multiple name node.
We could have anywhere between
six to eight name nodes.
Traditionally, the
architecture of HDFS
was that a single name
node could not scale.
So Hadoop community and
we invested a lot of time
in federation--
HDFS federation, client
side model tables--
to make it more scalable
to 12,500 hosts.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Wow.
And Joep, are you running your
Hadoop directly from Apache?
Or is it a vendor distribution?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Well, you
can imagine at our scale,
we're building our own
Hadoop distribution.
It is very close to Apache.
So when we first
started with Hadoop 2,
we were one of the earlier ones,
sort of on 2 oh zero alpha.
And then we worked
with the community.
There was a newer release.
Then we leapfrogged them
and jumped to the 2.2,
and et cetera, et cetera.
So we're very close to an
open source distribution,
maybe a couple of dozen, 200
patches difference, but very,
very close.
And those are
typically patches that
are going upstream, as well.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
Yeah, I know you
guys are a very major
contributor to open source--
Hadoop as well.
So thanks for that.
Vrushali, I'm curious
about the compute cores.
Half a million compute cores--
what Apache engines
are you running there?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: Hello?
So in data platform, we
support a bunch of technologies
for doing data processing.
Our production clusters
run Scalding jobs.
So most of our production
workload is all Scalding.
In addition to Scalding,
what we've seen
is people want to use--
people want to have different
ways of getting at the data.
They want to use
different technologies.
So we also have Spark, Hive,
Presto on our ad hoc clusters.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: So a
variety of them-- what
about the 300 petabytes of
logical storage, Vrushali.
What kind of data file
formats are you guys using?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: On HDFS,
we have LZO Thrift and Parquet
as our main file formats.
We also have a few
regular text files.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I see.
And, you know, Lohit,
this is something
that I found really interesting
when I worked with you guys
on this project--
that 1.5 trillion messages
a day, and even the 300
petabytes number.
How do you get to 1.5
trillion messages a day?
Surely, there's not quite
that many tweets per day?
And each tweet is only
about 280 characters.
How does that build
up to 300 petabytes?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Yeah, so
that's a very good question.
So the actual tweet text itself
is a very small percentage.
So whenever users
visit Twitter.com
or use the Twitter
mobile, there are
a lot of things they're doing--
the interactions, the timeline,
the order of tweets they see,
who do follow suggestions,
the search they do.
So all these actions generate
something called as events.
And we collect--
our framework is
capable of aggregating about
1.5 trillion events every day.
That's about one billion
events every minute.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Wow.
Yeah, this is a
massive migration.
Vrushali, can you talk a
bit about which teams were
involved to accomplish this?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: So for
the partly cloudy project,
it was not just the
Hadoop team at Twitter.
Pretty much all of the
teams in data infrastructure
were involved-- teams
that own Scalding, Presto,
the analytical data tools that
we have, all of the libraries.
And then it wasn't just
data infrastructure.
We actually worked
with several teams
at Twitter, like the
network engineering
team, the public cloud services
team, the platform security
team.
And then it was not just
Twitter going at this all alone.
We actually worked very
closely with Google on this.
We in fact have an on site
Google presence at Twitter.
So we have people from the
Google Professional Services
Organization who are
on site at Twitter
working very closely with us.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I
mean, Joep, you guys
seem like a very
competent Hadoop group.
Why did you decide to engage
Google Cloud Professional
Services on this engagement?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS:
Well, we know how
to run Hadoop
clusters on premise.
You can imagine that, as
many companies have done,
over the past decade, we've
built a lot of plumbing
and infrastructure.
And we-- it's like the larger
Twitter engineering work.
So from how we build
services, how we deploy them,
how we have configuration,
how we do monitoring,
how we do alerting, all of
that infrastructure is in place
and is build out for the
infrastructure within our data
centers itself.
So we know how to run clusters
and how to run services
in our own data centers.
As we decided to expand
that out to Google Cloud,
we decided to engage
with our Google partners
to make sure that we have a
much higher chance of success
in making this successful.
And through this
partnership, Google folks
have found out that some
of the Twitter cases
are slightly different maybe
than what you're used to.
And we've made improvements
alongside with you guys.
And on our side, we're
trying to adjust,
make sure that we do things
well on the cloud side.
And for our users, we're
trying to make sure that things
are as similar as we can.
So they have the same
experience on premise
as well as they have in cloud.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Interesting.
And Vrushali, what
are we looking at here
with the work streams?
How did you guys decide to
organize the different work
streams, I suppose?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
Right, so we
had this goal of
extending Twitter's data
platform to a hybrid cloud
model, on premises and cloud.
So in order to
reach this goal, we
started by identifying
the top broad work stream
areas that needed to
be done in order to get
to this hybrid model.
And as each work
stream began to evolve,
we came up with milestones.
And those milestones
brought forward
the dependencies
that existed between
the different components
and services that
needed to be completed in
order to reach that milestone.
And pretty much, as we
kept working on this,
we realized that we needed
a very close collaboration
between all of the teams, not
just within Twitter, but also
with Google to make this
adoption of GCP at Twitter
successful.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: So you
used an interesting word--
you said extending your data
architecture to the cloud.
Does that mean you're
keeping the on prem clusters
and extending the
feature set to the cloud,
or are you fully migrating
certain Hadoop clusters
to the cloud?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
So we are migrating
our ad hoc and our cold
data storage to GCP.
We are still keeping
our production clusters
on premises.
So some of the clusters will
continue to remain on premises.
And we will have new clusters,
like ad hoc clusters,
that will come up in GCP.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I see.
So here we're looking--
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS:
During the transition,
there will be clusters in
both on premise and in cloud.
So there will be a period
where both will be live--
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
They'll overlap.
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: --until the
migration is fully complete.
And at that point, we'll have
ad hoc clusters only in cloud.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Interesting.
Joep, can you walk us
through this diagram?
We're looking at the partly
cloudy architecture here.
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yeah,
what we're looking at here
is a little bit of our
target architecture.
As represented by the Twitter
birds on your left hand side,
that's all of our
users interacting
with the different systems.
As Lohit said, these users
generate all these events
that led in through our log
pipeline onto our RT clusters.
That's what we call
the real time clusters.
Those clusters are also used
to serve some outgoing data
sets into production servers.
And then that data is collected
through a log pipeline
and goes into
production servers.
This picture shows that
our ad hoc clusters
are fully migrating into cloud
is the target architecture.
And what we've done here is that
we're separating our storage
into GCS so that all of
the files and objects
are going to be stored in GCS.
And the analysis is going to be
running on both Hadoop clusters
as well as other tools.
We will have Presto
and other tools
that we will use, as well.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: So
the ad hoc cluster
has a Google compute
engine logo next to it.
Is that what you're using
to run your ad hoc clusters?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yeah,
the ad hoc clusters itself
will be large shared
clusters that we're
running on compute instances.
There's other cases
where we Dataproc.
That's underneath Presto.
That's an example.
There's other examples
where we spin up
temporary Dataproc clusters
to load data into BigQuery,
for example.
So there's other cases
where those are used.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I'm curious
to dig into that a little bit
more.
How did you guys decide to
move your stack from on prem,
as it is, I suppose, to
Google Cloud as opposed
to using a managed
service like Dataproc?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yeah,
there's the choice
to either have all of Dataproc
have everything as a managed
service.
You can imagine when you
run a handful of jobs
in a day then using
a cluster per job
is a totally
appropriate situation.
At our scale, when
we're running 80,000,
100,000, 150,000
jobs in a day, if you
were to launch 150,000
clusters in a day and then
have to keep track of
who run what where,
that becomes very
difficult to do.
At the same time,
it was also very
difficult to judge how big
that cluster needs to be.
So if there's an
ad hoc case, users
don't necessarily
know ahead of time
how big the cluster needs to be.
So if everybody were to
launch a 2,000 node cluster,
then that would be
very inefficient.
It would be very low
utilization at that point.
That's the reason why we're
running larger shared clusters.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I see,
multi-tenant clusters.
Yeah, I think that's
a really fair point
you're making about Dataproc.
Actually, last week we
released the GCP Broker service
to actually address an
integration of Dataproc
with curb rows
where you can have
multi users within a
Dataproc cluster, as well.
I'm also curious about the
Google Cloud Storage, Lohit.
What kind of buckets are
you guys using for GCS?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: So
for the most part,
we are using something called
as a dual region bucket where
if we load the data into
those buckets from two
of the regions, the
data will automatically
be replicated and consistently
be available from the two
regions not spread
across the entire region
like, for example, US
region, or something.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I see.
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS:
It looks like Asheem
has a question from Twitter.
ASHEEM: Yeah,
there were a couple
of questions around Dataproc,
which I think we answered.
But one new question
that came up
was how are you thinking about
storing tweet impression data?
What data models or
tools are you leveraging?
This is from Kat on Twitter.
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS:
So the question
is what data models
are we using?
ASHEEM: Yeah, so what
data models or tools
are you leveraging?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS:
So from our change
from on premise to
cloud, our users
are going to still
use the same tools
that they're using on prem.
So the change from
on premise to cloud
is not going to change the
format or the storage of how
tweets or our data is stored.
That remains the same.
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Yeah, so to
add to that, most of the data--
like so if a service,
a new microservice
is emitting some
events, they have a well
defined schema
associated with that.
And for the most part,
it's like a Thrift schema.
And then we compress
it using LZO.
So it's like a LZO Thrift
format as Vrushali told you.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: And Lohit,
talking more about disks,
are you using persistent disks,
as well, on the ad hoc cluster?
Because I can see Google
Cloud Storage there.
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: So
yes, it's a combination
of a persistent disk and GCS.
So what we are--
first, when we
started to evaluate,
we thought about
options of running
just HDFS on those VMs, which
would be very inefficient.
Because you need to replicate
like three ways for HDFS.
So what we ended up doing was--
in a MapReduce, generally
typically in an analytics
pipeline, a MapReduce
has multiple stages
where output of one stage
gets returned to disk.
And the next stage reads that
data, does some processing,
and then writes a disk again.
So for the intermediate
stages for fast access
and temporary data we are
using persistent disk.
But the initial input and
the final output is on GCS.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I see, so
the source of truth is GCS.
But you use the persistent
disk as shuffle space
or intermediate
job storage space.
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: And
the advantage of that,
as well, is that we can
now use other cloud native
tools to leverage that.
So if people want to use
Dataproc or in some cases
BigQuery, they can use
directly the data from GCS.
And we don't have to
store that multiple times.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I
see, so I definitely
want to dig a little bit
more into the details here.
But before we move on,
can you talk a little bit
about the log pipeline, Lohit?
What exactly is happening there?
And you're writing to
real time clusters.
And then it goes to
a production cluster.
What exactly does that
pipeline look like?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: So as I
said in the very beginning,
the actions, users actions,
generate a lot of these events.
So each of these
events has a name
associated with it, which
ultimately translates
to our data set name.
So the log pipeline is
responsible for aggregating
all the events which we
receive from thousands
of different servers,
aggregate all of them,
and then write it as log
files on HDFS, usually time
partitioned.
We do it on an hourly boundary.
We also do some cleansing,
format conversion,
depending on the data set.
And then we have a
replication framework,
which takes care of copying
the data from real time cluster
to production or other places.
I also do want to
mention that we call it
real time because those
are the clusters which
are the incoming clusters.
The uptime on those clusters
are like several years.
We rarely take
down that cluster.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Do
you run any Hadoop jobs
on those real time clusters?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: We
do not run Hadoop jobs,
mainly because of this reason.
Because Hadoop jobs
can be unpredictable,
depending on user actions.
So it's mostly these clusters
are incoming clusters
to get the data and then serve
some subset of data sets.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: So you
mentioned the data replicator.
I'm assuming the
data replicator is
moving the data from
these on premise
clusters between each other.
Can you talk a
little bit about how
it works when you use the
data replicator to move data
to the cloud?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Sure.
We already have a well defined
service data applicator
with given a source, and a
destination, and a data set,
it can keep track of
changes at the source
and make sure all the data
is synced to the destination.
Whenever new data
sets arrive in source,
it will make sure that
that data is replicated.
So for GCS, what we
did was we created
something called as
a copy cluster, which
is like an in
transit cluster which
has data connectivity
to the Google endpoints.
And we set up a
similar replicator
like how we have for on prem
for cloud also and then said,
OK, sources are
input, HDFS cluster,
and destination is GCS.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
This is interesting.
I mean, for the audience
members who might not
be familiar with
DistCp, can you explain
what distributed copy is?
And I'm kind of curious about
why the data-- is the data
replicator just kind of
kicking off DistCp jobs?
Or what is it
exactly doing there?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Sure.
So as I said, for
a particular data
set we have a well
defined partitions,
in this case, hourly partitions.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I see that, and
the year, month, day, hour, I
guess.
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Hour, right,
for this data set on ClusterX.
So what the data
replicator does here
is that for every new hourly
partition it sees at the source
it kicks off one DistCp job.
So the DistCp job is our
standard MapReduce application.
It basically copies a
lot of files in parallel,
taking advantage of the
parallelism of a Hadoop
cluster.
So, if you want to
make it go fast,
you just throw in more mappers.
And then it can copy the data.
So that's the DistCp job,
which is reading the data.
And, here, you can see
that the copy cluster,
even though it's
a Hadoop cluster,
it never saves any data locally.
It's not stored in the copy
cluster and then copied to GCS.
It's a pass through DistCp.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I see,
and Joep, what is that--
sorry-- oh, Asheem, go ahead.
ASHEEM: So there was another
question around security,
but I think we can tackle this
on a Presto question, which
is similar.
Did you have to make any changes
for Presto to work on GCP?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
So yes, I think
that's on the previous slide.
So we are running some Presto
clusters in GCP, as well.
We had to make some
changes to Presto.
And those changes were
basically required
because we wanted to follow our
triple-a design principles, so
triple-a meaning authentication,
authorization, and auditing.
So authentication is when users
identify themselves as who
they are.
So if a user says-- let's
say I say I'm Vrushali.
I need to identify myself, let's
say with my driver's license
or something.
I should be able
to say who I am.
That is authentication.
Authorization is when
we want to make sure
that users can actually
access the data that they're
trying to access.
So are they authorized
to access that data?
And auditing is when
we want to know who
accessed which data set, when?
And we wanted to
have a very clear cut
way of determining that.
So those three triple-a
design principles
made us make some
changes to Presto.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
Interesting, and Presto
has a Dataproc logo next to it.
Is that what you guys are
using right now to run Presto?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
Yes, that is correct.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: OK, can
you talk a little bit
about the scale that you guys
have benchmarked or tested
Presto in Google Cloud?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: So
we've run Dataproc with about--
Presto with about 90,000 cores.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
That's interesting,
because I think that's the
largest Dataproc cluster that
has ever been launched, as far
as I know for public customers.
Before we move on into a--
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Hold my beer.
We'll launch more
large clusters soon.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
OK, well, you'll
beat your own record
very soon, then.
Before we move away from the
data replication slide, Lohit,
I'm curious also about
the 800 gigabits.
I mean, that's a very fat
network pipe to say the least.
How is that network configured?
How do you handle
security around that?
I'm curious.
LOHIT VIJAYARENU:
Yeah, so when we
decided to set up these
copy replication from our
on prem Hadoop clusters to GCS,
what we decided was the data--
there are some
metadata operations,
which the data replicator
or services has
to do to say look up the source
and destination directory,
make sure all the
files are there or not.
Those are metadata operations.
But the actual bulk
transfer, the data transfer
would be in the order
of petabytes of data.
So our network engineers,
with the Google folks,
what they ended up doing
is to do a Twitter,
Google PNI set up, a private
interconnect between us
and will provide a 800
gigabits per second bandwidth.
Now all the nodes
in the copy cluster
have direct access
to the GCS endpoints.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Is that
what the orange thing is?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU:
So the orange thing
is very interesting stuff.
That is the Google
Hadoop connector.
So Hadoop file system is
like an abstract system.
HDFS is, in fact,
just an implementation
of that interface.
So what Google
ended up doing was
they implemented
the same interface.
So any API file system API
calls would be automatically
translated to the Google
Cloud Storage APIs
using that connector.
It's like a library.
So the advantage now
is that any application
which is using the Hadoop APIs
don't need to change anything.
So they can interact
with Google Cloud Storage
as if it's like any
other Hadoop storage.
So for the most part, we didn't
have to make any code changes
in the data replicator.
So we just plugged it in.
And then GCP would just work.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Sure.
I definitely want to come back
to the GCS connector again.
I know that there were some
really interesting developments
that happened in GCS connector
because of the Twitter project.
But before I move away from
this slide, Joep, I'm curious.
800 gigabits, that's a fat
pipe, like I said before.
So that means--
I just did math
before this talk.
One petabyte you can move
in just under three hours.
So 300 petabytes
would be about 35 days
if you have the pipe
running at full stream.
With that in mind, how long
is this data migration project
taking?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yeah,
we've done some modeling.
And if you were to go full
bore and pump it across,
it would take about four months.
Keep in mind that this data is
not a steady data set, either.
New pieces of information
keep coming in.
And in the days of privacy
and data protection and GDPR
regulations, some of
these data sets of ours
are getting scrubbed.
So it used to be
that, for example,
an hour worth of
tweets was written once
and would never be changed.
We would consider it to
be very cold data sets.
Their written once, and only
the new hours are coming in.
As you have a right
to be forgotten
and those kind of
functionalities
have to be implemented,
some of these partitions
actually get rewritten.
So as the time goes by,
as you're copying data,
and as it progressing,
some of this data
is changing and is modifying.
So the way we're setting
this up and the reason
why we have a copy cluster
is that that is also
providing some funneling where
we can do prioritization.
The latest hour can
be copied first.
And then in the valley
of-- during the peak,
you have the new hour
of data that comes in.
And then in the valley,
when the network traffic
is less utilized, we can
do the backfill part.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I say.
Vrushali, can you
give us just a sense
of how many data sets
are involved that you
have on premise at Twitter?
And is this all moving to
one massive GCS bucket?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
So when we
were thinking of how to move
this data set on HDFS into GCS,
we had a few different options.
Either we could just put
everything in one bucket
and have everybody access it.
But then that doesn't
sound very good, right?
So we had the other option of
trying to group together data
sets and put them
in some buckets.
But then the model
that we picked
was going with the data
set ownership model.
So every data set owner--
per data set owner,
we create one bucket.
And that is what
we ended up with.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: How
many data sets are there?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
About hundreds of data sets.
Close to thousand-- I
mean, 1,000, I would say.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: And how do
you organize your architecture
within Google Cloud?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: So
for organizing these buckets,
we wanted to think about how we
want to put them in projects.
Either we could put them
again in one project
and have everybody just run
all of their resources there.
But then at our scale, that
becomes too big and unwieldy.
So then we thought about
going the other extreme that
would be having one project
per small application.
But again, at our scale, that
becomes too big to manage.
So we picked a middle ground.
And we said, OK, let's have a
one project per business unit.
So for example, for Twitter
infrastructure engineering
we have one GCP project.
For Twitter revenue,
we have one.
So that way we have a
few handful of projects
that we can manage.
And then we organize our
buckets within those projects.
So having a few
projects does give us
some delineation, some
boundaries between what we want
to do across these projects.
But then we have a few
of them to manage--
not too many or just one.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Sure,
I mean-- so Joep,
I understand the scope
of these projects
are just like billing scopes
and perhaps security scopes.
But what exactly is
in these projects?
I see a Hadoop logo
and a GCS bucket?
So how many Hadoop clusters are
you running in these projects?
And how many GCS buckets
are on these projects?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS:
Yeah, like you said,
the project is a delineation
and there's a security boundary,
as well.
So within each project, we're
running one Hadoop cluster
that is shared.
And this is, again, done
for fragmentation purposes.
If you had one very
large cluster, that
would be great from
fragmentation perspective,
because all the users bin
pack very well together.
If you were to go to
the very other extreme
where you run one
cluster per job,
you have a huge amount
of fragmentation.
And whenever the cluster
is not fully used,
it's going to sit around idle.
So we chose the middle
ground where we end up
delineating, saying one cluster
for each of these pillar
projects, or pillar
organizations, we call them.
And then all of the
buckets that belong
to all of the users that are
in that pillar organization
fall along those lines.
So there will be a set
of buckets for each user.
There will be a set of
buckets for each log category.
And to clarify, when
we think of data sets,
there's roughly two sets of data
sets that we're thinking of.
You have the initial
log categories.
And that's an order
of magnitude of 1,000.
And then you have about
1,000 individual users,
order of magnitude of that.
And they each have dozens
of their own data sets.
So the total number of
data sets is fairly large.
But if you think of the
incoming log categories
that Lohit explained, that's
order of magnitude of 1,000.
So it will be several
thousand buckets
for each of these projects.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Interesting.
So Vrushali, I want to
go back to the triple-a--
I think you said authentication,
authorization, and auditing?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
That is right, yes.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I
want to go back to that
and think about
that a little bit.
So authentication, I think
that's just a user says
they are who they are.
Authorization, you've
got to give them
permission to do something.
And finally, auditing--
can you talk a little bit
about that in respect to how
you set up your security model
and user permissions for Hadoop?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
Right, so let's start
by understanding how
users do their work
on premises and in GCP.
So we have users, that's
the blue figure there.
So every user has a
Unix account that they
use to run their day
to day on premise jobs,
in cluster, whatever
work they need to do.
Now this user also
has a G Suite account
that they use for their
email, their Google Docs,
Sheets, all of that work.
Now, when we think
about a process running,
the process runs as a Unix user.
Now that process needs to
read data or write to GCS.
Now in order to
do that, it needs
to have the right permissions.
One way access the data
in GCS is via G Suite.
But then that means that you
need to provision the G Suite
credentials on the VM node.
We did not want to do that.
So we pick--
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Why?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: So
we do not want to provision
the G Suite credentials
on a particular VM,
because a person who has
admin privileges on the VM
then can act as that user.
So then that person would
have access to their G Suite--
Google Docs, Gmail, all of that.
So on the VMs, we provision
a shadow account--
what we call as a
shadow account--
per user.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
What is a shadowing?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
So a shadow account
is nothing but a Google service
account that exists in GCP.
And there is one GCP
account, one GCP service
account per Unix user.
And a Google service
account has a set
of keys associated with it.
And those keys and that account
is provisioned on those VMs.
So that way you only have
that account and the key
that is existing on that node.
But it is transparent
to the user themselves
when they are running a job.
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Think of
that as when you park your car
and you come and you
have valet parking.
When you hand over
your key, you may not
want the person parking
your car to be able to get
into your glove compartment.
But this is actually
one step further.
If you want to also
be able to say, well,
this person can drive your
car and can drive slow,
but they cannot
drive to the freeway.
They can drive around, but
they cannot have a party
in the back.
That's not OK.
So this, essentially,
is a different set
of keys that provides you a
subset of functionality that
act a little bit as
the user, but not
in all particular accounts.
So when a Hadoop cluster runs
a jump under my credentials
and Lohit is an administrator,
he can see the task running,
but he cannot access my
Google account on Gmail
or in my Google Drive.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: But these
are just normal Google service
accounts.
It sounds like you're
multiplexing them
within the same
cluster to some extent.
You're sharing many of them
within the same cluster.
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: So there
is one Google service account
per Unix user.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Per user, OK.
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
And only that Unix user
can read the keys or access the
keys of that service account.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
Yeah, but, Joep, that
sounds like a security flaw.
I mean, if you have one
service account per user,
what if that gets compromised?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Well keys
getting compromised is always
a bad situation.
In this case, it's
actually better
if a key gets
compromised to have
the shadow key compromised.
Because then the user can
access only GCS and not
their G Suite account.
In addition to that, we
end up rotating these keys.
So it becomes a
little bit easier.
This is transparent for
each individual user.
So when a user logs
in or SSHs into a box
and they access a Hadoop
cluster or they access GCS,
transparently behind the
scenes the shadow account keys
are being leveraged.
And those keys can
rotate over time.
And they're valid
only for a few days.
That is much simpler than
their G Suite account keys
or other keys that may
have to live longer
and that users
could be aware of.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: So just
stepping back, Lohit,
can you walk me through
the user experience?
Imagine I'm an
engineer at Twitter.
I want to submit a Hadoop job.
And now I want to submit
it to Google cloud.
How is my user
experience different?
What am I doing?
Am I SSH-ing into something new?
Am I submitting it
through a browser?
How do I actually
submit a Hadoop job
once Twitter is in Google Cloud?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: So that's
a very good question.
Most of the foundational stuff
which we have been building
is to make sure that users
have a uniform way of accessing
the stuff in GCS just like
how they do internally.
So what we ended up doing
in this particular case
is that we created
something called jump hosts,
or call like nest
boxes where users log
in using their Unix account.
Once they log into that
box, automatically we
provision their shadow account's
JSON key only for them.
It will be accessible
only for them,
using which they can access
any of the GCP resources.
Along with that,
some of the resources
we also provision their
G Suite permissions
to access some data.
So if there are tools such
as BigQuery where they
have to access it from UI--
so since the access to the data
and the tables, in this case,
have been granted
permission, they
will be able to access either
via web browser or these jump
hosts.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
One last question--
I mean, before we
go to Asheem, who
seems to-- there's another
question from the audience.
But before that, you
mentioned the nest box.
You SSH into the nest box.
You submit the job.
On premise, I'm assuming
it's the same thing.
So you're saying the
user's experience
is kind of very similar.
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Exactly.
So the same tools which
users have used on prem,
they are made available on
those nest boxes, as well.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
But what about GCS?
Can users still access GCS
through the Google Cloud
console through
their web browser?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Yes, they can.
And they can also use the--
as I have mentioned earlier,
there is this Google
Hadoop connector.
So using that, we have created
mappings for the users.
So just like they access HDFS
using Hadoop commands and then
a well defined path, we have
created a new [INAUDIBLE] point
for the GCS to say /GCS and then
any path within [INAUDIBLE]..
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I see, so
instead of HDFS name node name,
it's just GS, I believe.
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Yes.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: So it's
kind of transparent.
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Exactly.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Asheem,
do you have a question?
ASHEEM: There are two last
questions before we open it
up to the floor later.
First, since
BigQuery came up, did
you think of replacing parts
or all of your Hadoop cluster
with BigQuery and Bigtable?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: The
short answer is yes.
We are thinking we will probably
have a combination of both.
So some use cases they will be
more appropriate on BigQuery.
Other cases, Presto is
more appropriate for us.
And other cases, users are still
using Hadoop to run their jobs.
Because they're doing analysis.
And then later on, they will
run that same job in production.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Joep,
how do your users decide
if they want to run a SQL
query through Presto, or Spark,
or Hive?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS:
The exact details
of how we're going
to decide between all
of the various cases, we're
going to still determine.
And we're doing an--
we're going to run an
earlier alpha test mode
now with some of our users.
And we're going to find out what
the most appropriate tool is.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Cool.
Was there another
question, Asheem?
ASHEEM: And last question from
online is this must cost a ton.
Do you have any tips
to take advantage
of how to keep the
costs under control,
particularly with regards
to Dataproc and GCS?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: So I
think being in the cloud model,
being in GCP, there are a
lot of advantages to that.
Rather than looking at
just the cost, if you
look at the advantages that
we get by Google's networking
setup--
the fact that we can separate
compute and storage, right--
all of those advantages add up.
So it's really difficult to
say whether we are focusing
on the storage cost versus
all of these other advantages
that we are getting.
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: This is
also one of the reasons
why we're running a larger
shared Hadoop cluster where
individual jobs can
interleave together.
So if there's a job--
there's multiple stages
of a MapReduce job,
and the job's, for example, at
a stage with a single reducer,
the cluster's not going
to sit around idle.
Because other users will
use that same cluster.
We'll end up being able
to very closely monitor
which users use which
resources and have a mapping.
And at the end our
users are going
to be responsible--
our engineers are
responsible to
make sure that they
use the tools in an
appropriate manner.
This is the same as
what we do on premise.
Sometimes users will run jobs--
we sometimes see jobs
that are running 300,000
mappers and 200,000 reducers.
This can happen.
And it's a balance
between making
it as simple as we can
for users to use and not
have to think about it
and, at the same time,
if the cost becomes
very high, then users
have to rationalize
and think through,
is this the most appropriate
thing to do for a business?
And they make that choice.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: You
mentioned something
that I think is worth diving
a little bit more into.
You mentioned
separation of compute
from storage, which
is not what you
learn about when you read like
Hadoop, the Definitive Guide.
The whole idea of Hadoop is to
keep storage close to compute.
There's many benefits
there, like the map task
can start near where one of
the three replicas of the data
block is.
When you separated out
Hadoop at your scale,
separate out storage onto
GCS and then separately ran
Hadoop clusters--
I think-- can you share
more about your thinking
there and around any challenges
you ran into when you
did something at that scale?
And I'm also curious, when
you store something in GCS,
can one Hadoop cluster
read from that?
Can many Hadoop
clusters read from that?
And just talk about the
pros and cons about that.
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Well, I'll
answer the second question
first, because that's
the simpler one.
And the first question
I'll hand over to Lohit.
Yes, one of the reasons
why we stored data in GCS
is because then it can be
shared across multiple users
if they have the
appropriate access.
So there's access
models around that.
So data stored in GCS can
be used by multiple users
from various clusters.
That's the one
mechanism how to share.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
Across many projects.
So one GCS bucket can serve
two external projects, as well?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: That's right.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: So
that goes back to,
I think, this slide, where you
have one GCS in like Twitter
product.
But the revenue team
can read from that
if permissions were scoped.
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Correct.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I see.
So Lohit, can you talk
more about that decision
to separate compute from storage
around any technical challenges
you saw there?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU:
So traditionally,
like HDFS when it became very
popular over the last decade--
so the local
compute was the key.
Basically, wherever
the data is, you
send your compute there
to be more efficient.
And over the years,
what happened
was you build these
large clusters,
say 2,000, 5,000 node clusters.
And if you need
more compute, there
was no other option other than
either changing your machine
configuration or adding extra
nodes with more disk anyways,
right?
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Sure.
LOHIT VIJAYARENU:
So that model kind
of changed altogether when
the storage and the compute
could be now separated
independently.
So for example, one
example is that we
tend to replicate
the same data set
across multiple different
clusters based on use cases.
But with the storage
system such as GCS,
you just store one copy.
And then multiple
compute instances
can independently access them.
So there is definitely a bit
of a performance difference.
But, for the most part,
when you factor in
how the network is laid out in
GCP, and how you're caching,
and how you're organizing
your jobs, it kind of adds up.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I see.
You saw no performance
degradations in doing
that type of separation?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: For most
of the batch analytics,
when we did the performance
evaluation last year--
Derek and Dave also shared
a lot of information
about that in
their Google NEXT--
for the most part, we saw
very consistent performance
from GCP.
And then it was
almost one is to one.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Wow.
I definitely want to
plug Derek Lyons' talk
on YouTube about this, as well.
You guys did a very
sophisticated analysis
with like GridMix and
Terra-Gen to understand
your synthetic simulation use
cases within Google Cloud.
So definitely do a
YouTube search on that.
So before we take questions
from the audience,
I want to talk a bit about
the new tools or Google Cloud
Platform improvements
that were needed
to support this migration.
Lohit, can you talk about the
data retention, for example?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Sure.
So GCS already provided Object
Lifecycle Management tools
to manage your data to
automatically delete it
based on, say, create
time, or something.
But for us, it is
much more complicated.
As I mentioned earlier,
we have data sets
which have an hourly partition.
And users usually configure
complext retential tools
such as any data which is
older than, say, 30 days, needs
to be deleted automatically.
And that decision
happens based on the path
of that data set, not the actual
create time or modification
time.
It's derived out of the path
of the particular data set.
Because there are cases
where we could backfill.
We could copy the entire data
set to a destination cluster.
Or we could scrub the
data to make some changes.
So such a functionality
was not available on GCS.
So with the Google
engineers, there
is now an open source tool
called SDRS, supplementary data
retention service, which is also
open source, which kind of does
a similar thing on GCP, as well.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Where
is it open source at?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Its on GitHub.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: I believe
it's in Google Cloud Platform
GitHub.
OK, so I'm trying to understand
a little bit more around this.
You're saying Object Lifecycle
Management in GCS indeed
works on object creation time.
You showed us hourly time
partitioned data sets before.
You're saying those
are like event times?
Event of what?
Event of when the
tweet took place?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: So those
are the times in which
that message got created.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: On
the real time clusters?
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: On
the real time clusters.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: So
that's time stamped.
And you want to expire
data based on that time,
not the object
creation time, in case
there's delays on the log
pipeline, I'm guessing.
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: That is right.
So as I said, when we copy the
data from our HDFS cluster--
lets take an example
of our initial copy.
The seed copy we would copy is
a few months of data onto GCS.
There we cannot set OLM policy
saying that anything older than
30 days, get rid of it.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
It's just all new.
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: Exactly.
So that is the reason why we
had to come up with this tool.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Interesting.
What about demigods, Vrushali?
That's an interesting
sounding name.
Many gods-- what is that?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
So demigod
is basically a group
of services that we
use to configure Twitter's GCP
platform for partly cloudy.
The name demigod
comes from the fact
that these are admin services.
These are admin processes.
But they have privileges
that are exactly scoped
to whatever they need to do.
So it's like a demigod.
It's a godlike service, but
not quite all of the admin
privileges, but only that
which-- what it needs to do.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: What
do they do, though?
They have semi admin privileges.
What do they do?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN:
So these services
are responsible for creating
buckets, creating shadow
accounts, granting IAM policies
on buckets, key management,
all of that.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Oh,
interesting, so provisioning
those service accounts
that we talked
about earlier, or making these
hundreds or thousands of GCS
buckets.
It sounds like automation tools?
Is that fair to say?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: Yes.
So these are automated
tools that Google--
that we have that
are running in GCP.
These are event driven services.
So, for example, when
users join LDAP groups
or when we make config
changes to our files,
that's when these services
get triggered, and they run.
And then they reset
the state of the system
to what it's expected to be.
So if somebody makes a
manual change on a bucket,
the demigod service
will go and reset
the state to whatever
it should be.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Interesting,
what about the bucket
move rename tool?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: So, as
we were working with buckets
and getting familiar
with GCP, we
realized that we
needed the ability
to move buckets across
projects or to change
the name of buckets.
We wanted to work
with buckets as we
were working on our design.
That is when we wanted
a tool from Google.
And we put forward
this request to Google.
And they built an
open source tool.
It's on GitHub, as well.
So it can move buckets
across projects.
It can rename them.
There are several configuration
options that it takes.
Yeah, feel free to look it up.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: And
that's on GitHub,
I believe, for Google
Cloud Platform, as well.
I think that's a
really useful tool.
GCS buckets are
globally namespaced.
So I think you have
to have just one name.
So I'm guessing this
tool does something
like deletes that name and
stores the data temporarily,
and recreates that name
in a different project
and just moves it over?
VRUSHALI CHANNAPATTAN: Yes.
So this tool basically creates
a temporary swap bucket.
It first copies over
all of the data.
And when it starts
that, it actually
locks the incoming
bucket so that you don't
keep making changes there.
And then, once all of the
data has been copied over,
it will delete this bucket and
then recreate the same bucket
in a different project
or with a different name,
and then copy over the data from
the temporary bucket into that.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: That
sounds super useful.
Joep, can you tell us a
little bit about the HDFS
to GCS checksum feature?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yeah,
this is one feature
that we added in
collaboration with Google
in order to make sure
that the checksums match
all the way from the source all
the way through to the target.
The checksumming mechanism in
HDFS is different than in GCS.
And this is a feature that's
been added HDFS side to make
sure that the checksums
can check all the way
through from end to end.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Very cool.
And I believe this work was
actually done in open source
Apache HDFS, correct?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yes,
initially one of my team members
implemented this first
and is running that.
Because not all of
our clusters have been
upgraded to that version yet.
And they worked with
Google engineers.
And that's done in
open source, yes.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Very cool.
And finally, Joep,
can you tell us
a little bit about GCS connector
2.0 performance improvements?
I should tell-- let
the audience know--
that in the next
week or two, we are
going to increment the
version of GCS connector
from 1.x to 2.0.
And there's a couple of dozen
major improvements in there,
a lot of which were driven
by the Twitter project.
Can you tell us a little bit
about some of that, Joep?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yeah, one of
the features that's been added
is this cooperative
locking mechanism feature
where you can imagine an
object store functions very
different than a file system.
In an object store, there is
no such thing as an i note
where directories are
a first class citizen.
So, as items move
around, it's possible
that people move directories.
SAMEER FAROOQUI: Cool, so it
locks a directory, I suppose,
before it modifies
that directory?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS:
Yup, a lock is taken
so that multiple uses
moving around directories
don't collide with one another.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
And I believe this
is in alpha stage right now.
But it should be
coming out very soon.
All right, so, to start
wrapping up, Joep,
can you tell us a little
bit about this special URL
that you had talked about
at the very beginning?
JOEP ROTTINGHUIS: Yeah,
Google is hosting a page
on cloud.google.com/twitter.
We'll be hosting a
list of links there,
and resources, and the
things that we're working on
together and collaborating on.
We're working on a
series of blog posts.
So those we'll be
linking there as well.
And all the talks
will be linked there.
So, if people want to follow
along and collaborate with us
on these projects, they can
find all this information
over there.
SAMEER FAROOQUI:
Cool, and yeah, I
would love to see a lot
more of the details of what
you guys are doing in
the next year or so.
I did want to give a plug to
a few upcoming Twitter talks
in the next couple of days.
So take a quick
screenshot of this
if you guys are interested.
And, for the live Q&A,
check out Twitter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]